el cuerpo humano tiene 5 litros de
sangre del cual el 40 por ciento son
glóbulos rojos cada glóbulo rojo tiene
aproximadamente un volumen de 90 por 10
a la menos 15 litros cuantos glóbulos
rojos hay en el cuerpo humano escribe tu
respuesta connotación científica
redondeando al segundo lugar decimal ok
entonces tenemos que en el cuerpo humano
hay 5 litros de sangre ok
5 litros de sangre del cual el 40% 40%
son glóbulos rojos ahora lo que nos
interesa es cuántos glóbulos rojos hay
en el cuerpo humano sólo el 40 por
ciento de los 5 litros de sangre son
glóbulos rojos y para sacar el 40% de 5
litros lo que hacemos es multiplicar 5
litros por punto 40 cierto multiplicar
por punto 40 es equivalente a tomar el
40 por ciento de esta cantidad ahora
también nos dicen cuál es el volumen de
cada glóbulo rojo nos dicen que es de 90
por 10 a la menos 15 litros entonces sí
ya sabemos cuál es el volumen total en
el cuerpo humano de glóbulos rojos y
tenemos el volumen de cada uno de los
glóbulos rojos podemos encontrar cuántos
glóbulos rojos hay dividiendo el volumen
total de glóbulos rojos
el volumen de cada glóbulo que es 90 por
10 a la menos quince litros
litros bueno por lo menos lo que
llevamos hasta aquí nos dice que vamos
por buen camino porque en las unidades
con las que estamos trabajando se
cancelen y entonces lo que nos va a
quedar aquí es simplemente un número y
la cantidad de glóbulos rojos que hay en
el cuerpo humano es simplemente un
número entonces damos por buen camino
pero bueno entonces vamos a simplificar
tenemos por aquí cinco por punto 45 por
punto 4 es igual a 2 y eso es todo lo
que nos queda en el numerador sin
embargo en el denominador tenemos 90 por
10 a la menos quince ahora esto aunque
se parece mucho a la notación científica
no está escrito anotación científica
porque este número de aquí si es mayor o
igual que 1 pero no es menor que 10 y
para que esto esté escrito en notación
científica éste tiene que ser
estrictamente menor que 10
ahora claramente esto se puede modificar
muy fácilmente para que si está escrito
en notación científica lo único que
tenemos que hacer es reescribir lo
aunque hay tenemos aquí 90 que se puede
escribir como 9 que ya es estrictamente
menor que 10 y mayor o igual que 19 por
eso es 90 y lo estamos multiplicando por
10 al menos 15 entonces lo que obtenemos
es 9 por 10 digamos que es 10 a la 1 que
sigue siendo 10 por 10 a lo menos 15
pues como tienen la misma base en además
tenemos que sumar los exponentes y nos
queda 10 al menos 14 ahora esta fracción
la tenemos que simplificar más esto es
igual a 2 entre 9 por 1 entre 10 a la
menos 14
y ahora cuánto vale 1 entre 10 a la
menos 14 y aquí tenemos en el exponente
este símbolo de menos que significa 1 /
entonces aquí en realidad tenemos 1
entre 1 entre 10 a la 14 y eso es
exactamente igual a 10 a la 14 entonces
esto de aquí
es igual a 10 a la 14 bueno pero todavía
nos falta escribirlo en notación
científica porque resulta que esta
fracción de aquí es menor que 1 ahora
como le vamos a hacer para arreglar eso
pues vamos a multiplicar por un 1 muy
conveniente que va a estar escrito en la
forma de 10 entre 10 que aquí estamos
multiplicando por un 1 que es 10 entre
10 pero queremos asociar este 10 para
multiplicarlo con el 2 y este 1 entre 10
lo va a absorber este 10 a la 14
entonces esto es igual a 2 por 10 entre
9 por 10 a la 14 entre 10 cierto esto es
exactamente igual a esto aquí
multiplicamos por un 1 que aquí estamos
dividiendo en dos pedazos aquí está el
por 10 y aquí está el entre 10 pero
bueno el chiste es que esto es igual a 2
por 10 es 20 que se está dividiendo
entre 9 por 10 a la 14 entre 10
eso es 10 a la 13 y esta fracción ya es
mayor o igual que 1 y estrictamente
menor que 10 entonces ya estamos muy
cerca de termine nada más tenemos que
escribir esto en notación de zimmer así
es que vamos a realizar esta división
por aquí tenemos 20 y estamos dividiendo
entre 9 el 9 cabe dos veces dentro del
20 2 por 9
y 8 y 20 menos 18 nos sobran 2 ponemos
un punto bajamos un 0 y creo que ya
sabes cómo continúa esta historia no o
sea tenemos por aquí un 9 queremos ver
cuántas veces cabe dentro del 20 que es
el mismo caso que teníamos por aquí así
es que ya sabemos que por aquí va un 22
por 918 20 menos 18 es 2 como estamos
del lado derecho del punto decimal
podemos bajar otro 0 el 9 cabe dos veces
dentro del 20 y nos sobren
2 bajamos otro 0 y así nos podemos
seguir un buen rato sin embargo
aquí nos dijeron que redondeará mos el
resultado al segundo lugar decimal así
es que podemos quedarnos simplemente con
esto
y tenemos que esto de aquí es muy
parecido a 2.22 que es una aproximación
de esta fracción de aquí por 10 a la 13
10 a la 13
entonces hay aproximadamente 2.2 por 10
a la 13 glóbulos rojos en el cuerpo
humano